well in 2015 two Islamic extremists
attacked a Mohammed cartoon contest in
Garland Texas fortunately they were both
killed by police before they killed
anyone else but it easily could have
been a massacre and it would have been
thanks believe it or not to the FBI an
undercover agent egged on those
attackers he traveled with them to the
attack site and then fled when the
attack began no effort was made by the
FBI to stop the terrorists and no
warning was given to local police
Bruce Joyner was a security guard on the
scene that day he was shot in the attack
not surprisingly he's suing the FBI he
joins us tonight along with his attorney
Trenton Samuels thanks both very much
for joining us
Bruce Joyner first to you in this story
is so incredible it's so hard to believe
that the FBI would have participated in
something like that I want to make sure
I'm not mistaking the facts in the open
is that correct an FBI agent accompanied
these guys to the scene of the shooting
yes he was in a vehicle behind their
vehicle in Tucker we also know that he
was taking a picture at the exact spot
of the shooting in fact of Bruce Joyner
seconds before the shooting broke out so
what could possibly been and again this
story's been around for several years
but it hasn't really penetrated I don't
think to the extent it should into the
public consciousness what would possibly
be the reason for the FBI knowing a
terror attack was going to take place
and allowing it to happen anyway well
Chuck Tucker what's interesting about it
is the FBI and their court filings have
said this this wasn't a rogue agent this
wasn't you know someone that went off
off of policy he acted exactly according
to their directions from the top down
and you know it's troubling because from
the top down we've seen problems with
this story Jim Comey shortly after the
attack said that these guys were like
needles in a haystack in no way were
they on the radar of the FBI when in
fact Elton Simpson one of the two
shooters had been followed had been
monitored for years by the FBI hundreds
of thousands of dollars had been spent
investigate
the exact individual who later carried
on an attack like the one that they
thought many years ago would take place
so it's odd for sure seems like a sure
does seem that way so what's the
identity of this FBI agent who was at
the scene so that they went through
painstaking efforts to keep his identity
secret and in fact he's he just recently
testified in a in a related trial in
Cleveland and they cleared the courtroom
they took an unusual step in not
allowing even any witnesses to watch him
testify you had to listen in via audio
from the next room over so he is he is
their guy I mean they have they have
owned him from start to finish and from
our perspective it's a problem when he's
the same guy who told these terrorists
who tear up Texas days before the attack
he then seemingly is escorting them
holding their hand all the way to the
attack and then he's taking a picture
when the attack takes place and he tries
to flee and I mean the whole point of
this is to prevent terror attacks and
now we're sitting in the presence of a
man who was shot in a terror attack an
American Bruce I mean you were shot how
do you what's your reaction to this does
it seem like the country you grew up in
no this is a former law enforcement and
this is not how you run undercover
anything there you have to have control
of the situation and make sure that no
innocent people are harmed and so this
is this is not normal
have they into wait let me just ask the
obvious question which I should have
started with have they apologized to you
since you were shot in this operation no
no in no way they apologized no that's
disgusting
gentlemen I'm you know I'm sure there's
a lot to this that I don't understand
what they said I do I really wish you
luck in this lawsuit I think all of us
deserve to know what exactly happened so
Godspeed thank you thank you so much
Tucker